and get started
so thank you uh thank you all for uh
coming and listening to me uh thank you
to uh triangle pi data for organizing
this uh
like you said my name is
sergio farragut that's the americanized
version sergio ferrara for those of you
who speak spanish
i am a technology evangelist at imply
and uh
i'm here to talk to you about some like
it hot
um
so
this is a presentation about
the
data uh temperature spectrum so we're
going to talk about what
makes use cases hot and cold
we're going to go on a tour of database
technologies over the years and how
we've addressed the analytics space
over the years and how things are
changing
and we'll meet apache druid that's the
database technology that is an open
source uh project it's the an apache
project
um and i'll describe how apache fits i
mean how apache drew it fits in the
temperature spectrum or where it fits
and we'll try to answer the question of
whether we can have it all
right uh
and i'll uh
advance a little answer on that and as
always it depends right and we'll talk
about how it depends and you know where
it applies to which use cases
so with that um i'll start the
describing uh hot and cold things uh
we're going to talk about hot use cases
as an image for that we have
takis and hot cheetos and i think that's
a corn with a lot of uh
a lot of some red spice
so hot stuff
um and also about uh cold things right
the as an image we have
the the uh
old uh
warehouse full of cold cheese and uh so
in these two uh realms uh and when
talking about data um the cold use cases
uh
tend to be about the
slower queries and
you know nobody likes a slow curry right
everybody wants a query to respond
quickly but the reality is that some use
cases don't require extremely fast uh
responses right there's a batch
reporting which you know could take
potentially hours to run as long as the
reports are ready by uh by the morning
but by whenever they're the users the
business users need them or it could be
some more ad-hoc querying tool where you
know you submit some kind of uh report
generation uh that's more ad hoc but uh
you're fine with going off grabbing a
coffee and then coming back to see the
results um and and so in these use cases
the data is usually not so fresh so
typically they're batch loaded we have
uh
data that's loaded maybe on a daily
basis that's a more common uh thing uh
some may be more frequent than that uh
but
it's really about uh
putting the data in known query patterns
right so you have predefined reports
that may be parameterized but but the
the way the data is being accessed is
known right they're the using known
aggregations known uh known access paths
um concurrency tends to be lower in
these uh use cases typically these are a
set of power users uh that are driving
them um and these are these are the
people who know the data well right the
these are the people who know the the er
diagram uh from top to bottom maybe they
uh help design it um
so these uh cold data use cases
typically serve uh strategic planning uh
analytics or longer term decision making
right decisions are uh
in days or weeks uh in in their time
frame so that's the cold use case
the uh hot use case on the other hand
is about uh extremely fast response
times right these are sub second to a
few second response times um it's
typically on extremely fresh data so uh
these are uh queries on events that have
just occurred the the aspiration is to
uh be able to analyze data in real time
as the events are occurring
these applications tend to have much
higher concurrency and we'll go through
a few use cases as to why that is um
and there's an expectation
given this this fast response time
they tend to
create very highly interactive
experiences right the users uh spend a
lot of time in these tools because it's
that interactive uh experience that
allows them to have a conversation with
the data rather than
a question that takes a few minutes to
respond right um so so that's sort of a
quick distinction of hot and cold use
cases uh let's talk about a few of these
use cases in in the in the hot
arena um risk and fraud right that's a a
traditional case there is a credit card
fraud right and
one of the aspects of that is you really
you need to be able to analyze
transactions very quickly right so you
need you need first of all you need the
data that's fresh uh and it needs
confidence in in determining whether uh
it's a fraudulent uh transaction or not
um so so this is a use case that needs
fresh data and potentially has lots of
volumes of data
um data driven applications so these are
you know
websites or or mobile apps that
that use some form of analytics
these tend to have very high currency
right the
websites tend to serve millions of users
uh mobile apps uh even more um so
one of their characteristics is very
high concurrency and also very rapid uh
response times right the expectation in
a in a mobile app or in a website is
that you click and you get a response
within
within a few seconds
at the at the higher end right um or
immediately in the uh
in the users expectations so the user's
expectations here are for rapid
interaction with uh with the application
uh network performance is another use
case where that's very operational in
nature right it needs to have access to
uh to data about network traffic uh as
an example or about the current state of
devices um so metrics about the devices
uh and all of that data needs to be very
fresh in order to be useful and to to
provide
the ability to act on uh traffic
patterns that are problematic or device
failures that are problematic and to be
able to act quickly to provide rel uh
reliable network services
um clickstream is another use case where
freshness matters a lot right in order
to understand the journey that a user is
undergoing
through a website uh through a
sequence of clicks
the data needs to be fresh
these use cases are maybe roll outs of
new channels a b testing
and the point is it requires a lot of
ad hoc exploration of the data slicing
and dicing comparing perhaps the uh the
current activity the current events to
uh historical patterns so so this also
brings uh um
this idea of having not just the fresh
data but also some historical data to
provide context and be able to query it
um and the use cases continue right the
typical one and and we have examples
here in our sponsors uh are in the ad
tech industry um actually druid comes
out of that industry uh it comes out of
the need uh to build this uh interactive
analytic experience
um and and all of these use cases uh
provide
require a few things from their from the
data from the data platform right um the
the solutions need to scale with the
number of users so they need to be
highly scalable
um there it's very important that the
data that that we're putting in front of
people is fresh data
and they need to enable this ability to
explore and to power observability
of for these applications so these
things are what makes them hot
this slide tends to uh you know describe
the differences between hot and cold i'm
not going to read through all of them
but uh to point out the the the
main differences here um the hot data
use cases have an emphasis for speed and
for
democrat democratization of the data
um
they uh enable exploratory personalized
decision making right so so there's an
ad hoc nature to it
um and it's all catalyzed by the fact
that it has the latest data it's fresh
data so these again are the
characteristics of uh the hotline
so what's driving this um well um one
thing is uh gen z right in the 20 teens
and the 2020s uh we started seeing the
this this appearance of users that
have certain expectations right they
they expect applications to react to the
current context right whatever that
current context may be it may be
location personalization that the user
has they expect interactions that are
trusted and secure
they expect an interface that's simple
and intuitive and primarily they expect
a high interactivity right this idea of
real time interaction
um
imply the company i work for produces
one of these uh visualization tools
that's uh called implied pivot
um
this is actually the the the driving
force behind the creation of the
database right so so druid is
the database that uh
this application relies on that this
application was born out of the need to
create this analytic experience that was
uh that could you know cross uh many
dimensions and calculate all sort of
aggregations and could do it on the fly
right and that created a need for a
database that could do these things that
could do ad hoc queries that was highly
scalable that would provide fast
response times and
in the end provide an interactive
experience for the end user um one thing
i like to point out about this slide and
the videos that we're seeing is that uh
it's not uh these are not the time lapse
video videos right these are actual
real-time experiences uh using this
application uh so you can see where the
response time to the change in how you
know the user is uh
is splitting the data or re-aggregating
the data or filtering further in the
data is extremely fast and that's what
we mean by a hot data experience
and it's not just us right one of the uh
you know while imply is uh one of the uh
main committers to the apache druid
project it's not
it's not just uh imply that is building
apache druid
it's a apache druid is a mature uh
project now it's been around for quite a
few years uh and it was very early on
because of the problems it solved it was
adopted by many uh companies in silicon
valley these tech companies had big data
problems and which turned into big scale
problems and they decided to adopt druid
to solve these problems so as a few
examples netflix uses this uh for
real-time insights on their on their
users experiences right so
they analyze uh the the uh the streaming
of uh of the shows and the movies and
they analyze events such as buffering
events or or delays
of other kinds such that they're
understanding their own users experience
and in real time reacting to problems in
the infrastructure that may be adversely
affecting their user experience right so
they use druid to provide a reliable
service
mopab a twitter subsidiary
is using druid to query terabytes of
advertising data in just seconds airbnb
uses it
to do digital service analytics
the point here is is that all of these
uh
tech companies from silicon valley are
participating in part
and
helping us build this apache to a
database that provides all this
functionality
now um druid is not just about implied
pivot right implied pivot is a
visualization tool that uses the the the
ability of the the performance and the
scalability of the druid database to
provide a visualization and analytics
but it's not just
that drew it is a database and it allows
for
uh jdbc connected uh sql or uh through
json uh actually through restful apis
that are json based to uh for other
applications to support druid and we're
seeing um lots of other well-known
reporting and visualization tools that
are adopting the druid database uh
officially supporting the database
um
and
like you we we're we're uh
we want more people like you to from the
community to be involved in the
community and i'll go through a few
examples here of
the community
describing how they're using druid and
uh and talking about it publicly so
there's a series of videos here uh about
uh other uh companies and how they
they're using druid and how they're
implementing their uh hot uh analytics
applications uh target uses it to drive
their uh enterprise dashboard and
analytics platform
game analytics uses it to analyze how
gamers interact with games so the game
developers are the the customers for uh
game analytics and they use this uh
platform to understand how
their
users are interacting with their games
and how to improve those uh gaming
experiences
you know watts
is uh another druid user that uh uses it
to power consumption i mean to analyze
power consumption patterns uh in
millions of households
so oh and one more uh preset uses druid
and profit to drive interactive
predictive analytics
um so
it's it's an active community right then
that's a
part of what's uh driving the success of
apache druid as a solution for for hot
analytics um we also have the druid
forum where you can find many of these
experiences it's a it's a space where
people describe their use cases and and
uh
and uh give us insights and tips and
tricks and on how they're using druid to
implement it
so it's a great place to go to to find
inspiration to build your own hot
analytic applications
so after all this you know the hot and
cold uh use cases uh it begs the
question why uh tolerate cold databases
at all right why not just make
everything hot and make everything have
this amazing analytic performance
and the answer is uh money right it's a
it has a cost to a cost in memory and
cpu and disks and network to build uh uh
these uh uh hot analog platforms it also
requires human skill and time to build
these interactive experiences so
the business case needs to be there
right for for the really hot use cases
and we'll talk a little bit more about
that and what distinguishes the use
cases and when to use one technology or
another
so we've talked about the data the
temperature spectrum um that we now
understand what's cold and what's hot or
what we mean by cold and hot um so now i
want to take you on a tour
of uh how
the database technology has evolved over
the years and uh and how we've
addressed or how this anal this
analytics space has appeared and how
it's been addressed over here over the
years
so we start with uh
you know this idea of the relational
database uh and uh the fact that you
know one size fits all right we had well
in my case i was uh implementing uh
applications using informix using sybase
oracle comes to mind um so these uh
relational databases appear and we start
building applications right we started
building applications to store orders to
manage stock levels to do order
processing to manage our customer list
suppliers purchase orders you name it
right everything you need to operate the
business right and and this these are
our
for the first time we're starting to
generate digital uh data right we're
starting to store this data and
we can start reporting on it so these
applications also have a certain
reporting or analytics uh capabilities
built into them
to build you know sales reports and and
uh some level of analytics to drive to
help drive the business
and you know single database it has the
data why not right
we can we can uh run the queries there
so we start running the queries there
and while the volume the data volumes
are low while the customer counts are
low everything's fine the query has run
okay
um but as uh these uh applications start
succeeding and the businesses get uh
bigger more customers more data we start
keeping more data
we see that the queries start getting
slower and not just that it uh
it starts interfering with the operation
of the business because the analytic
queries start slowing down the regular
transactions in the database and that
starts uh interfering with the operation
of the business
so
the first change comes in uh you know in
the late 80s early 90s uh we see the
appearance of uh the data warehouse
what's the idea here the idea is we
offload uh some of the the data that's
that was being stored in the is oltp now
named the online transaction processing
databases that are used for the
operating business
we offload data from there keep the data
low so that the transactions or the
transactional speed is guaranteed and we
can
make sure that the operation of the
business continues
um so in order to extract the data the
this new concept appears the x the etl
process which is stands for extracting
the data from the old tp database
transforming it
into some centralized form and loading
it into this
data warehouse technology which
is probably another at this stage is
another relational database
so now we have this the transactional uh
the the operation of the business on the
transactional database we're moving some
data out on a regular basis and we're
building this data warehouse and now
we're running reports and analytics on
this other database
one of the things that that came out of
this the data warehousing i was a part
of that uh i it the they became large
projects right
they required us to understand the
business uh understand the business
questions that needed to be answered um
understand what data we needed in order
to answer those business questions so
that we needed to analyze the the
sources of data understand those do
modeling of the data how are we going to
represent the data in this data
warehouse and then do those
transformations load load that data and
start reporting on them um
these technologies required you know
expensive disk expensive compute uh in
order to provide uh this uh data
warehousing capability
at this stage scaling these technologies
was kind of hard um you know it wasn't
like in the cloud right now where
everything's elastic it was you know you
if you wanted to grow your your uh your
data warehouse you were probably either
going to buy a whole bunch of new
servers or replace the set of servers
that you had it was more complex
but even these data warehouses as the
the as time went on and as uh app more
applications appeared uh generated more
users generated more data generated more
questions and they also started getting
slower
in in relational technologies right so
that made it that made them colder and
in many cases unusable by some of the
business so the next step comes in we
start uh pushing some of the data from
the data warehouse out into uh these
olap databases online analytical
processing database
right typically uh they have a subset of
the data
most of it is uh in some summarized
forms so there's aggregates instead of
raw data and there's probably just a few
tables it's not all of the detailed data
that we uh we're keeping in the data
warehouse this provides you know hot
summarized data it provides hot
analytics and it enables uh hotter use
cases
and the hotter user experience
um
so this this this works right we start
uh creating more olaf databases these
are the uh the the the hot use case and
uh um things like scaling out start
appearing in the mid 2000s so we start
using parallelism right which means we
start dividing the
the data into uh into pieces and
spreading it out among multiple servers
so we're scaling by adding servers no
longer scaling by making uh servers
bigger
and on the oltp side
suddenly we see that this this trend is
also following we see the appearance of
something called sharding
which is partitioning the transactional
databases in some form to again keep the
data volumes low uh and manageable and
maybe we're splitting them by customer
or geography or stores
by whatever makes sense to split the
data uh to enable the transactional
speeds that we need to enable the
business volume that has now grown
um
so sharding keeps the volume down and
manageable for each of the compute units
and this concept of scaling out starts
to appear everywhere
the data warehouse also scales like we
said before but it's expensive to grow
and it's expensive to build and this
olap databases are starting to appear
more and more and they're getting a
little hard to manage
right so somewhere down the line uh
around the uh
what was it the probably late 2000s
early 2010s
um we see the appearance of this new
concept called the data lake which is
pure unadultered storage right the the
uh it's a
distributed file system it's resilient
it uh it guarantees that whatever we put
there will be there when we want to read
it um it's a scalable so it can uh it's
because it's distributed it's scalable
so it can grow to hold any amount of
data that we want um technologies like
hadoop with hdfs or cloud data likes
appear like s3
and the idea here is that
the data
is kept in its source form right and we
want to keep all of the data right it's
either batched into the data lake uh
like it was in the data warehouse case
or it starts to get streamed right
we start seeing uh change data capture
technologies on the source databases
that are feeding into
streaming technologies like kafka
that can deliver
in real time all of this data into the
data link
right this having all of this data in
its source form uh enables some
innovation right the users can now uh
access all the data and the this concept
of schema and read appears and uh the
the
a set of query engines that are also
scalable
start to appear to address uh reading
data from uh this data lake right and
processing it
now
it seemed like etl had disappeared in
this case because we're just batching
the source data the way it is and and
putting it into this data lake but the
reality is it hasn't gone away right etl
is not just about the moving data it's
also about cleansing data about
enriching data and end users are still
looking for you know reliable reports
and kpis so
cleansing and enrichment is probably
something that still needs to be done
this work needs to be done
um but it's moved
so everything in this landscape is now
scalable and that's a good thing
but the
in this query engine promises to replace
the data warehouse functions right the
things like
kafka i mean like hive and presto up
here
but there's a new latency problem from
the oltp uh to the end users right and
it's not just about technical throughput
there there are certain aspects about
technical throughput because the data is
not necessarily stored in a form that is
uh
optimized for the analytics that you're
trying to do so there's some when you're
querying there's some transformation uh
occurring that uh in order to produce
query results and that produces more
latency but there's also this idea of
additional latency in
the production of the the the reports or
the analytics themselves because now we
have we need specialists right on uh the
data that understand how to read that
the data in the data lake um so there's
these curators of the data living living
along the stream of uh
of data flow
um many of the queries are still slow
so we fixed the storage problem we fixed
the scalability problem but we have a
new problem right the the performance uh
the latency that we want between the
oltp systems and the analytics isn't
quite there
and uh to make matters a little worse um
i'm trying to go to the next slide there
we go um
we we now have other sources of data
right the the types and sources of data
begins to explode it's not just
relational databases anymore right it's
these highly distributed uh no-nothing
applications that are running on mobile
phones and medical appliances solar
panels sensors and beehives even in cows
in the fields
um and so so we've got all these new
sources of data that we also need to put
in the data lake um and we see the
appearance of a specialized database uh
that
is uh we're calling here the serving
database and these databases are a
little different than the query inches
right because they they store
an optimized copy of the data that's
designed much like in the past with the
olap databases they're storing it in a
form that is optimized for decision
making and
that use the latest techniques in
computer science to to deliver
new uh new performance levels right we
see the appearance of key value uh
stores
such as hbase and cassandra
this space is where
apache druid lives so apache druid is a
serving database
for analytics so let's uh talk a little
bit more about apache druid
um
like we said before the apache druid
community uh
has helped build this technology right
and these contributions from this uh
these big silicon valley engineering
teams uh come because they are they are
driven to build the best serving
database possible they're trying to
solve this problem of a database for
very high concurrency very low latency
so very fast response times and
flexibility to do
any kind of query or to do a large
variety of queries
unlike key value stores
right and druid is uh
actually a columnar uh database
um so it's uh
much like uh some of the olap uh
database that we're talking about before
that use columnarization as an
optimization for analytics uh or like or
c or parquet files that store data in in
a columnar form
for the same reason
now druid adds on to this druid
integrates into its storage mechanism um
highly efficient indexes on all of the
columns
and it also
does resource management so it
automatically distributes data
across the resources to enable that hot
data performance and enable the highly
concurrent workloads
um and it adds one extra piece of magic
right the something that pulls it out of
the batch architectures and
we think really revolutionizes decision
making and that is
the addition of connect connecting
streams directly to the database so
the what's the idea here um
we're
while we're still
loading uh batch data from the data lake
and that's still uh viable in druid we
create another lane a streaming lane
that connects directly to the stream so
directly to the change data capture
that's coming from
the
transact the source systems or the other
sources of data that are producing data
in a continuous basis and the idea is
that
the data be visible for analysis in real
time as soon as it's posted into the
stream it becomes available uh for
analytics and for queries so and you
imagine combining this with in-flight
data processing uh whether you put the
data processing inside the stream or
something hooked uh to the end of the
stream
this allows you to tap into sources of
data and make decisions really fast
so
with druid you have a database that
delivers on this hot analytics it
provides super fast query responses
on fresh data because it could connect
directly to the streams it's enabled for
lots of concurrent users and it creates
this highly interactive interface that
we were showing
because it it enables it through the
response times that it that it enables
but not everything not all data is hot
and not all use cases are hot right so
if you there's a use case uh for uh
cooler data you could use a query engine
something like presto that uses uh
a pure query engine to access the the
data from the uh
the data lake directly or perhaps it's a
cloud data warehouse that uh that's
processing the data
those are
warm or colder use cases apache druid is
definitely just for the hot use cases
so as a hot database with its you know
sub second response times or a few
second response times
we can make analytics personal
interactive and intuitive
having the fresh data allows people to
make rapid decisions on
new on the most current information
the scalability allows us to enrich
enrich and lengthen the time frame of
the data that we can see
and therefore expanding the audience for
analytics
so we've talked about the history of
of database technologies and how it uh
it has addressed the this analytic space
um now what i'd like to do is is go into
uh druid right and what makes druid
different right why is apache druid
capable of producing these uh uh really
uh hot uh data experiences
so uh first let's talk a little bit
about its architecture
so uh druid uses
a micro service style architecture um
it's a
host well it's a it's a collection of
microservices that provide different
functions um on master servers we see
the coordinator and zookeeper that
provide um the uh
that manage the health and manage the
balance of data across the cluster and
they provide inter reliable into process
communication um we have data processes
in the data servers the ones that are
called historical and indexers that
provide the ability to ingest data and
make it available for querying
um
queries come through the top on the on
the query server in the service called
broker
the broker's job is to distribute query
work so it receives a request for a a
query
it
decides how to separate that into pieces
of work that it distributes among the
data servers the data servers process
their results they return them to the
broker the broker joins the results and
does final processing to return it to
the user
um the data servers are where most of
the scalability occurs right that you
can
add more historicals and indexers to
enable more uh ingestion capability and
more uh query capability
um now notice at the bottom of this uh
diagram there's something called deep
storage
this is where we put all of the data
that's available for query and you see
that we've subdivided the data into like
these chunks that we call segments right
this is uh
these are
individual columnar uh indexed
compressed uh
storage uh formats that are uh
generated by the indexer so as the data
is ingested either in streaming or in
batch fashion uh by the indexers the
indexers are responsible
for responding to queries in real time
with the data that they're consuming and
they have in memory and and also
producing these uh data segments these
uh columnar compressed optimized formats
and pushing them into deep storage
the historicals on the other hand pull
their pieces or their segments of data
uh into their uh local storage and into
their local memory cache to respond to
queries about longer time frame uh
longer time frame data
um so that's the architecture uh that
drives uh druid
um
we've done uh well this is actually not
one of we do benchmarks but this is a
one of our benchmarks this is a
third-party benchmark by an
academic database research group where
they
experimented with different levels of
data so different scale factors and
that's why the three different sets of
columns comparing druid uh with hive and
druid with presto
and you can see here the extreme
differences in performance and this is
because of the way uh not just because
of the architecture that i just showed
but because of the way that the database
stores the data so i'm going to talk a
bit about that
so
what
what is this this uh segment structure
that we're talking about right that
makes a druid different it uh
it uses a column or form so data's
restored data is stored in columns
which allows it to compress each of the
columns independently and based on the
specific data types which gives us good
compression
it also uh uses uh secondary indexes and
this is automatic uh it generates all of
the secondary indexes for all of the uh
for all of the dimensions in the data
set
uh it uses uh it operates on the
compressed data right so the it resolves
the queries directly on the compressed
data and it uses late materialization to
uh
bring back the original values to
produce the results right so and we'll
go into details as to how that works uh
over the next few slides
so
let's talk about an example
um so in a typical segment we'll have
millions of rows
actually the recommendation is around
five million rows per segment
but you know the slide only shows eight
because that's uh what fits on the slide
um and the the the the first column in
any uh segment in druid is uh is a time
column and this is stored as a 64-bit
integer uh column and this is because uh
druid is a time series database it
separates uh the the event data uh by
in the timeline
by segments so the first uh partitioning
key used is time
um all the other columns uh that the
that are being ingested either through
streaming or batch um are also stored in
columnar form um
and that means that you know we're
storing the individual values of the
rows uh for each of the artist columns
in each of the city columns in this case
but we don't store the the the
the literal values of the artist and the
city instead
i'm sorry is there a question
no i i think you're good uh okay okay
yeah
that was that just echo i think that's
fine um so so uh
these dictionaries uh we build
dictionaries for each of the columns
right inside a segment and what these
contain is for each distinct value of
the column uh we do an encoding so and
we sort those values so we see here in
this example we have acdc kylie and
silverchair uh each of them get are
sorted and they each get an encoded
value zero one and two so the encoded
value is what's stored in the column
data and therefore it's uh that that by
itself uh provides some compression
same is true here in this example for
the city call
additionally um
druid
as
i jumped ahead sorry let me jump back
produces indexes for each of these
columns right and it does this
automatically what does this do it for
each of the values in the dictionary uh
for the column
it stores uh which rows contain uh set
value right and it also stores it in
what's called the roaring bitmap form
and what this is is it's a bit field
where you know there's a one for the
well there's a bit for each row and
there's a one where the value is present
and a zero where the value is not
present
so this seems
rather simple simplistic but it's
actually quite useful right
for
filtering because
by using the dictionaries which are
sorted we can quickly find the encoded
value with the encoded value we can find
the the position in the index and with
the position in the index we can know
which rows are needed now if there's
multiple filters across
many columns um or using you know
multiple values or multiple
column filters
we can very easily use the bitmaps the
bitmap indexes to do
bitwise and or not operation which are
lightning fast in producing uh the the
end filter result and telling us where
which rows we actually need to look at
so that's one of the key optimizations
um
additionally we'll have the the measure
columns these are where the numbers are
right in this case it's price and count
that we're storing um and this is where
we're gonna
do calculations on right so
this is the structure of uh or the the
how
druid stores the data uh internally
and uh
what i'm gonna show you now is how it
uses this uh to resolve queries right so
first of all you know we we in again in
this hot data experience uh it's
important to allow for
almost any query right so so here we're
expecting users to uh you know do
aggregations on any of the measure
columns we're expecting them to provide
any uh set of filtering and complex
conditions for for filtering uh we
expect them to do uh grouping by any of
the uh dimensional columns in the in the
data sets uh and then do calculate
aggregate calculations on those so these
are not um
developer driven um
query keys right these are your truly
user driven queries that that are
driving this so that's the the ad hoc
side of this
so how does uh uh
how does this structure help in solving
those queries and that's what i'll walk
through next right so if we have uh
an example here of uh of this uh query
we have the artist uh equal to ac dc
right so
what's this when we take this segment of
data we can quickly look at the
dictionary for that column and look and
do a quick search we're not scanning the
data at any of these steps and that's an
important aspect of this right we're
doing an optimized search on a sorted
list and finding ac dc in this list and
finding what the encoded value is for
that and with that we can jump down to
the index to the the
position in the index that corresponds
to that encoded value and quickly
determine which rows across the data set
are the relevant rows
um
additionally uh we can just pick out
from the city uh column or store and
from the price column or store because
those are the the the two columns that
we're uh grouping by and doing
calculations on and we know which rows
within those columns to to access
because of the index that we uh that we
did so we grab that array we do the
calculation uh notice that we're doing
the calculation on city but still with
the encoded values right this is the
that late materialization uh aspect of
this so we do that uh calculus
and only then after the result is is
obtained we do the materialization of
those encoded values into the city names
of sydney and perth and produce the
result
so you see how the how storing the data
in this form enables very quick
query capabilities
in typical analytic query fashion
so
we've gone through have a quick question
sure
so based on these ones i think that the
result should be good look what in our
situation what we are seeing is right
if i query the console through druid
console the results are good if i query
through hive the results are good
but if i query through presto
the results are not good i mean that we
are getting the different reasons so we
try to see the roll up is
used anywhere by loading we are not and
the data types are same
as approved by that
we don't know why
and i'm not sure where to look um
that sounds like something we should
take offline but uh it's uh
so
just to understand that you said that
the the results through druid through
the druid console to directly querying
to
but when you query through presto and
you're occurring through presto into
druid
yes
okay you know i'm not familiar with
anybody doing that yet uh
i'm somewhat new at this
it as well um
but uh i'd be interested in uh in having
a further conversation with you
later
but let's uh let's uh leave it for later
okay um
so
we've talked about these concepts
i'm sorry to interrupt you again uh
there is another
person who raised their hand already uh
go ahead please
yeah i would love to ask one more
question about this about the
materialization
so in this particular case each of those
cities is a single word and so there was
only one id shown
uh prior to the turning it into the city
but let's say it was a multi-word city
like even three words
was it stored in the dictionary as one
entry for all three words and so there's
only one id there but what's important
in the dictionary is three separate
words and where there's three separate
ids associated that you'll then
materialize to reconstruct
no no it's it's actually by value right
so so the dictionary is built by the
distinct values of this of the uh of the
column itself so in the case that you're
describing whether where it's a
multi-word name it the the whole name
would be uh encoded in the dictionary
not the individual words gotcha so this
approach works much better for small
fields than for large
more textual fields
you wouldn't want to use this kind of
approach for that
um i guess it depends it's not really
dependent on the size of the field i
would say um
where it shines most i would say is
where the cardinality is uh lower right
in very high cardinality uh columns uh
the the performance isn't as great right
or the compression capability isn't that
compression for sure isn't this great
yeah okay that makes perfect sense i
understand okay cool
all right um so unless there are more
questions i'll i'll i'll move on um so
so we've covered you know the key
principles of druid's design you know
this idea of a segment which is an
optimized storage format that gives us
compression it gives us secondary
indexes it gives us operations on the
compressed data and it gives us this
well we're just discussing the the late
materialization um
so it it's really a different query
processing system to other
other query engines out there and it's
designed for this use case right for the
hot analytic use case
so
now let's uh try to answer the original
question about can we have it all right
and like we said before is it depends
right so so let's uh do a little bit of
a review of
what differences are between uh apache
druid as a as a serving database versus
other query engines that provide other
functionalities right so druid
like we said provides both batch and
streaming ingestion
it can use data from the data lake to do
backfills and or batch updates of data
or add high confidence data to enrich
to enrich other data but it also has
this ability of streaming data right and
providing real time providing data
freshness and being able to query the
data as it's being ingested
so druid is not just a query engine
right it's a database it
ingests data and stores it in an
optimized form it caches data in memory
it partitions and indexes it it balances
it across the components to enable uh
not just high availability but the scale
and
the performance that it promises
uh right so it's it's beyond the query
engine on top of the data lake now the
query engine does have some advantages
right the query engine can um do uh can
fetch data on demand it doesn't require
ingestion right because it's just a
query engine it's creating data that's
uh stored in some other form in another
place
um
the these both druid and these query
engines typically are elastic they're
fault tolerant they're shared nothing
architectures so from that perspective
they're very similar
druid can scale up or down
just by adding or removing processes in
that architecture picture we showed if
you add historicals it'll distribute the
data further and therefore have a better
performance for for bigger queries um it
rebalances and self heals but in order
to do that it needs to do some work
right needs to redistribute some of the
data
so when you add a new uh new hardware or
new nodes uh or new uh pods in the
kubernetes world um
the that that
new uh resource is not immediately
available for for querying it needs to
do some work to
bring the data segments that correspond
to that new node uh to the node so that
it can respond to queries so that takes
a little time um and and therefore uh is
different than a query engine in the
query engine case you can do uh you can
bring in new nodes and they will and
because it doesn't have any local data
it can immediately be used for uh new
queries so those are those are
differences now the query engine is not
so fast right um so it's
there are different use cases for it
um
another example so based on everything
we've discussed right
by now you if you believe me
or if you test it you'll see that the
druid because it stores this optimized
copy will provide better performance
better performance when compared to
other query engines using the same
hardware as an example right and we saw
the benchmark there and how much uh how
much better performance it can actually
do
and it also provides a lower performance
floor this means that the the
the fast queries
and what we see in in druid is fast
queries that are around 100 milliseconds
to produce results um that's typically
not possible in query engines and that's
just because you know in order to access
the data from the data lake you may have
a higher latency than that right just to
just to read it and then process it and
it's not in an optimized form and so
forth right so so it doesn't provide
that speed but the query engines do
provide other functionalities right like
we said you can have spot elasticity
right by adding new nodes to it you can
use them immediately and and it gives
you that scale uh faster than uh than
druid might and it also provides other
functionalities like maybe like
federated uh data sources like presto
allows you to access multiple data
sources in order to produce results
while druid is is designed to produce
results based on the data that it has
ingested and not other data sources
so anyway there are different use cases
that uh
again we're saying for the hot use cases
use druid for the not so hot use cases
and maybe for other reasons like
federated data sources you may want to
use different query engine
so again
can we have it all well it's going to
depend right it depends on on uh whether
uh your use case uh
is really that hot right and whether
there's a business case for it um
there's community members like we've
talked about like netflix and hulu who
are reaping the benefits of these hotter
analytics and really uh providing a
business value through uh this hot
interactive analytic experience that the
druid provides
um so if you want you know the hot
cheetos download druid and use druid to
do it if you're looking for a cold
cheese well then maybe you can use
presto or some other cloud data
warehouse
um
so speaking of which uh the the uh if
you want to get involved uh the
druid project site is in druid apache
druid.apache.org
that contains
quick start tutorials and all of the
project documentation the quick start
tutorials are actually quite good to get
you started immediately i learned this
and downloaded it my first day
downloaded the
druid uh uh distribution got it up and
running and started doing uh ingestion
and queries within uh within an hour or
so
um so it's actually quite simple to do
um
there's also the github page for those
of you who are developers we this is an
open community and we welcome
contributions right so prs are welcome
even bug reports are welcome we we want
to improve as a community we're wanting
to improve this database as much as we
can
so we welcome all the contributions uh
and finally there's a forums right there
there's the druid user forum at
druidforum.org
there's meetups like this one where
we we talk and where we invite
our
our users or druid implementation
users to talk
and there's the druid professional
groups in linkedin there's the twitter
messages that you've probably seen
around uh there's a slack channel on the
apache software foundation
slack and there's the google groups that
for druid users that were
questions and answers also occur
so with that uh i'll say thank you and
uh i will open it up for more questions
if you have more questions
sergio i have a question sure uh
does the uh does the engine support the
druid engine itself support uh
partitioning
uh well let's say uh windowing functions
so in in tc and t sql different
implementations of sql you can use a
partitioned by or an over
uh keyword
and it it will
give you
views of the date views of the data that
are segment segmented by
right yep yeah so yeah so the
traditional uh windowing functions in
sql right
and the answer is not yet
right the the
there's a large number of sql functions
that are supported um including um many
approx we didn't talk about
approximations but the
part of what makes it so fast is it uses
theta sketches to do
approximations and that enables uh fast
queries
but the windowing functions have not
been
added to druid yet
any other questions
no problem
any other question guys
i have a question
sure
sergio um if you don't mind um just
curious uh
when you say um you have the uh
um
uh platform uh druid uh is it completely
open source just wondering completed
apache druid is completely open source
uh imply the the company i work for is
uh one of the one of the committers
along with netflix and hulu
and
and we
imply provides value uh ad function i
like imply pivot the the visualization
tool that that i showed and uh other
management tools for the database right
but the the database itself the apache
druid database is completely open source
cool yeah i i'm i'm very impressed with
the uh
the wandered and
nighty acts faster
than pesto that's really impressive yeah
and you know that's the primary reason
why it
receives so much adoption in in the uh
in the big data space right in the in
the analytics space in the real-time
analytics space particularly
absolutely absolutely
all right uh okay wrong you have
question go ahead
yeah i have one other question i'm a
little timid to ask this but i'm really
curious so so i'm actually a committer
on the
apachelusee.net project which is a
net port of the uh the java version
and
it's i've been only contributing that i
guess for a year or so and so i'm still
kind of a newbie as a contributor but
i've waited through so much technical
material to try to really understand the
lucian architecture and many of the
things that you talked about here in
druid are very reminiscent of things
that are in the scene that make lucene
so fast so like using bit fields where
individual bits represent you know a
state like and we've seen it an
individual bit will indicate whether the
record at that
index location exists or has been
deleted
and exist and the scene uses um segments
and they're um read-only segments which
i suppose your segments are probably the
only two
data which they call doc values um which
didn't used to exist in an old version
of the scene but got introduced i think
in 4.0
so there's a there looks
to be a lot of similar ideas here and so
i'm just really
curious
which one is probably cross-pollinating
the other one or or maybe the ideas flow
back and forth
you know i i'm not going to say that
druid is the only database that doing
optimized analytics
but it's a really good one um i i'm not
particularly familiar myself with lucine
all right but it sounds interesting and
you know this is one of the uh i guess
interesting aspects of open source right
you can try them both
right i don't i didn't mean it like uh
one is better than the other it's just a
from an architecture standpoint
many of the concepts that are giving
these two products the performance
they're getting
are similar and so seem to be maybe
cross-pollinating lucina's targeting it
at
being a search engine so its very first
incarnation was uh basically the search
engine to be excite
dot com if you remember a long time ago
excite so
um
lucine
is principally about
finding the data really really fast and
you may have lots of different words
right and you want to be able to narrow
down an enormous number of rows into
just a small number of rows very quickly
based on which ones might have the words
and so you can imagine kind of the bit
dictionaries and the column research and
all these kinds of things play into that
space really really well so lucian isn't
designed to compete with droid at all
interesting but i see some of the exact
same thinking in how the architecture
under the hood is
sure
and you know i i think a lot a lot of
the concepts across these open source
projects are like you said shared right
i mean there's a
you know this idea of unmutable uh files
that are have some form of optimization
is
now a common one right in the big data
right right none of the sql databases go
that route but but
it adds a lot of really cool
characteristics i mean it's mind-bending
at first that these files these segments
are immutable
um but once you get past that um it
actually there's a lot of benefits that
come from it i mean doing hot backups is
a piece of cake right i mean because
pegments are immutable one of the
interesting things about the druid in
this case remember the deep storage well
deep storage is usually uh placed
somewhere in in cloud storage right s3
is a common uh
implementation for deep storage and what
that means is that you don't really need
a backup
all right the backup is already in s3
because the data's immunized once you
put it there it's there and it's uh
reliably there right um
there's still you know the need to
protect against the uh maybe user error
um but uh but again these are immutable
so it's not like they're deleting
records although i would say one thing
right even though we use uh
immutable uh files uh once they're
created they're uh they're
never changed um
there are we also use uh mvcc so
multi-value concurrency control uh to
enable changes to those files so so data
can be changed and segments can be
produced again um and but what happens
is that the whole segment gets replaced
right sure
when it's the exact same way we use
version control so we can have multiple
versions and depending when you queried
it you'll query uh one version of the
segment versus another version of the
segment
and the other versions are then retired
from uh from the environment
point in time query very easily too i
don't know if you have that as a feature
but because the segments lay down
sequentially it it it facilitates point
in time queries as well really well
correct so it uh i'm not sure that we
have the like uh the point and time
query capability because we tend to
remove older versions
no i'm not that much of an expert yet so
i'll probably answer that question
better somewhere in the future
no worries thank you so much i learned
so so much
thank
you great discussion
great
great discussion i like it
all right um
anyone else who
still have any questions uh
i think uh you know what um if you do
have questions you're welcome to
um you know uh get contact
with um
uh mr uh mr uh sergio yourself and uh
sergio uh
if you don't mind can you um you know
input your uh email address in the chat
yeah so that people
may contact you uh after the session
uh
we are um strict on time actually um
all right thank you again uh sir sergio
and uh
with uh with uh
uh the next step proceeding let's
go to our second speaker
our second speaker is
juv
sakali
and drew is a machine learning
team lead at uh
sensibile
sensibile turns every day
spend into long-term financial awareness
i mean the financial uh wellness uh with
actionable and
purchase level data and also um
juve is one of our pi data triangle
organizers as well
so without further ado uh
let's uh welcome juve
drew can you um share your screen
yep um
so i'm going to be trying something new
this is a prezi presentation uh
i kind of see this inverted in my screen
but i would like to know if you're
seeing the presentation in the right
order
on the camera itself
well i see i see what could be a
presentation
off to your right
yep that's it so is it is the text
appearing correctly
uh
data comma ai and web 3 what when what
and why when how conclusion and
discussion
that's it that's it
okay uh so first of all thank you for
giving me the chance to talk about such
an abstract idea this is pretty
far-fetched and
kind of
kick sense captivism in the community
right now
so uh i wanted to tackle it anyhow
um
so uh just to get an idea about uh the
crowd uh
what kind of uh like what's your
sentiment around you know
the applicability of web3 i would like
to get that in um in the chat like if
you if you really like it one if you
hate it maybe maybe five
uh
that would be super helpful for me to
understand like what i couldn't talk to
you just
like put those things in the chat just a
number between one to five one being i'm
super excited about this and i am really
skeptical or i hate the whole
um
narrator
so how you feeling with web3
is that you're asking jew
right
okay
what's your like first impressions uh
that's that's where i wanted to get an
understanding of the community it's very
hard because i cannot see your faces
and
cool
cool so most people are asking
sorry well people are writing in um i'm
not sure mark you said you were able to
see his screen uh i'm not i'm not sure
if other people are
um
yep uh yeah i see a lot of threes and
fours uh no ones or twos so so that is
that is interesting
i think uh drew
is not sharing his screen now but uh you
know from his camera you can see
uh those uh you know uh
pictures
from his camera
yeah
it might be useful to just pin my camera
on on for everybody if that helps
yep now you're up thank you
yeah all right
um
all right let's so let's get started um
so i want to talk about uh how data and
ai can actually play in with web3 if it
is possible and what would be the
roadblocks
so let's get started with what and why
so um personally i feel we are at a
pretty exciting time where they're too
really overhyped kind of overhyped
or buzzwordy kind of technology is
simultaneously popping up just the web 3
movement and just the data in the eye
movement
um i'm personally on the data in ai side
i know very little about web3 so this is
my foray into web3
but but the intersection of these two uh
does uh kind of uh
bring about a new set of opportunities
that could help really um
booster some of the shortcomings that we
had up to
so let's let's dive in
so
what what is actually bringing about
this web 3 moment um and let me first uh
get a little bit into the limits of web
2.
um the closest definitions i've found
which made sense to me for web3 is uh
where i know web one was read only web 2
was rewrite web 3 enables read write own
um however i think it's uh
the way i kind of internalize this
definition is where rip web 2 was passed
by value in a function
uh web 3 is more by more like pass by
reference
and and we'll go go into some of those
details later um but that's my
definition
and the problem with web 2 is there were
some unintended consequences right like
um
what am i talking about for most
successful platforms like facebook
google uh we have become we became the
product our data
and collecting our data became like the
central focus of these organizations
also once you submit your data to
somebody you have limited control over
uh what they do with this data because
you just passed it on
um there's censorship so people can
choose what appears on web web as
central agencies like google could
actually completely ignore a bunch of
data um
and and they have right what kind of
results show up what doesn't show up so
they have monopoly about uh
a large chunk of how
internet and vector operates
we don't have good mechanisms for trust
verification so misinformation is
abundant and we have seen what it can do
to our society in general
um so
to so how did we get here like and and
if you if you take the the classical
machine learning or reinforcement
learning uh perspective towards things
like you're designing a system and
you're placing rewards in the wrong
places
you tend to elicit behaviors um that
that
try to still maximize their own uh
reward and in turn um
do not benefit the system
and one of the questions i would like to
pose here is
what is choice really when reward
structures have been defined
like do you really have a choice
when reward structures are in play
um i i want everybody to take a moment
to think about it
so
if if for doing bad or if the incentives
are provided
incentives are
for doing bad
to the to the common public does it
really make sense to have choice to do
good like and should it be a choice in
the first place
as intelligent machines
we are all kind of maximizing for
utility right and and
what whether what i mean there is you
have a set of choice uh choices actions
and each action leads to an outcome and
you're trying to take actions which
overall as a total um maximize utility
for yourself and this is pretty that is
this happens intuitively in any any
given system
you can see this in the animal behavior
you can see with reinforcement learning
agents as well
so
um
what what can
change this narrative
i think one of the key pieces is to
put rewards and incentive structures
that enable good behavior
and a part
and one of the ways you enable good
behavior is you make people owners
and and that's where this this whole
idea of web3 is pretty pretty
interesting to me personally uh so if
you if you have stake in the in the
system and you have stake in making the
system better
you would be driven towards making
better systems for everybody
versus if you're basically
interfaced through a third party um
where you have to like offload your data
and the third party then chooses what to
do do with the data so it will try to
maximize and set this for itself
and and that's that's where it starts to
uh become a little bit different
so
coming back to
our limitations one of the limitations
that is an active area of research is
the trust and privacy area and the gaps
are growing i think this is one of the
slides i was looking at a presentation
from
the mit csail
labs
and
they touched upon a lot of points where
you know we there are certain urgent
opportunities
and and two key proposals in this and i
i want everybody to just
you know take this picture and and
uh
hold it in your memory for some some
more time and download the presentation
i think will start making sense
so data usage and purpose
right now
we don't have proper mechanisms around
controlling how data gets used and this
was a suggestion around you know purpose
controls
through access controls
regarding which services can use and
cannot use your data
um from from that is collected from all
the devices
and the the the
the way they were describing the
architecture for this was to have a
purpose aware database where
each query has a purpose entity
kind of defined along with it
now this is a very interesting idea i
don't know how how
how well implemented it is in the
current world
and we have tools for that another idea
that was uh presented was around like
cryptdb where the sql itself and the sql
database itself was encryption aware
and again this was pretty exciting but
again none of this isn't in
in use at a global scale
so uh taking a step back right like how
how many people know this person
um you can you can write in the chat or
you can speak out loud
okay going once
going twice
uh
he's the inventor of internet uh tim tim
berners-lee
um he's also uh the um
oh yeah somebody got it conrad there you
go
um yeah so he a pretty pretty visionary
person and i'm going to read this verb
waiting because i i don't have a better
way to put this myself
his vision for internet when he created
it
in 1999 was
stating i have a dream for the web in
which computers become capable of
analyzing all the data on the web the
content the links and the transaction
between people computers
a semantic web which makes this possible
and
yet has yet to emerge but when it does
the day-to-day mechanisms of trade
bureaucracy in our daily lives will be
handled by machines talking to machines
the intelligent agents people have
touted for ages will finally materialize
so this was his vision going back in
1999 and i think it kind of ties back
into and
when semantic web was proposed was
proposed as web 3.0 uh that definition
got overridden by the current blockchain
technologies
so this was pretty interesting well
uh diving deeper so this is the stack
that that was proposed back then
and probably this has evolved over time
as well in which like trust proof
unifying logic cryptography these are
all integral to this this whole system
where i think it kind of diverges is
around how knowledge is encoded into the
system
um and the the kind of definition that
blockchain technologies right now
is instead of storing the knowledge
itself they are storing hashes of the of
them or basically indexes of the
knowledge
um and they kind of have moved away from
this whole rdf idea um but it's pretty
interesting that this was proposed way
back
and in 2005 there was another
slide i was able to dig deeper where he
also proposed a policy aware web where
you know transactions actually let me
make this bigger so the transactions
would have some kind of policy awareness
in inbuilt into the internet and then
you can probably approve or deny
transactions between machines based on
the policy
um so yeah
this this is not new new stuff this has
been uh vision proposed earlier and then
bitcoins come comes along and
the paper is very
easy to understand it's like nine pages
long and i highly recommend everybody to
read the paper
um one of the things it did pretty
interestingly was to define an incentive
structure that promotes good behavior
here i think it kind of highlights where
a greedy attacker if they want to
sabotage the network they'll have to
amass a sizable amount of compute power
and if they have already gone that far
it it becomes more profitable for them
to mine bitcoins rather than uh hurt the
network and destroy wealth so
that kind of
like bootstrapped
incentive mechanisms into the network
security and the usage
intent
also i introduced an idea of how things
could be made
private and this was pretty initial
stage of it but
one of the downsides of blockchain is
it's public and
you have to basically then separate out
the identity so the wallet that is
making the transaction does not need to
have
tied back to a real person a person can
have multiple wallets and the
transactions from
that result from a wallet are public so
there's an abstraction layer right right
here which is
right now being maintained by a third
party like a bank so bank has complete
information about who's this person they
do kyc and
all those things and
if data gets leaked or they want to
misuse that information they can so
that's where the problem comes from but
here that that kind of um gets resolved
also that there was the whole notion of
what a blockchain is and i'm going to
skip over this because i'm going to
assume people already know this by now
um but the idea of the wallet and this
again ties back to the identity
it's pretty interesting where a wallet
is a combination of a public key and a
private key if you have seen alice and
bob talking to each other in in multiple
you know public private key
conversations this is no different than
that
and
the public key is open for everybody to
see private key is what kind of uh helps
you enforce ownership so you don't
really store anything in the wallet per
se but a public key is attributed to
some amount of bitcoins and private keys
are used for access and and approving
transactions
so
um the way i have understood wallets is
a wallet in a blockchain and web 3 world
is the same as a browser an internet or
maybe an ip interest in internet on web
world
so and that's my definition
any questions so far i would love to
take a pause and answer anything
if something has come up
um so that was bitcoin uh then came
ethereum and one of the
things that it did pretty well was it
made the whole it created a layer of a
programmable layer on top of blockchain
and this was
a huge addition when it kind of took us
closer to the semantic web proposition
where the transactions can the whole
internet is computable at that point and
two main
main things that have been introduced
from there and these are standards as
well so we talk about smart contracts
it's a it's a standard of communication
um
and it allows you to kind of piece
together distributed apps called apps
which are
immutable pieces of code that live on
blockchain and that can
perform transactions on the blockchain
so this was one of the biggest addition
now the other thing that has really
caught fire is around non-fungible
tokens which is another standard it's a
721 standard and what it does it allows
you to represent something that is
unique on the blockchain it's just a
token
and the non-fungible aspect just means
it cannot be equated like two
hundred dollar bills are fungible they
they have the same value but a
non-fungible token is something like um
a property a house that is unique by
itself and the properties are not
um
like completely equivalent to something
else
so that's where the notion of
non-fungible comes in but um
representing something unique is pretty
easy on a blockchain if you have a token
associated to it
now
it kind of goes hand in hand with uh
identity so if something is is unique
it's it's represented in the blockchain
and it is associated to your wallet you
can prove that you own something
and and and that kind of creates um
opportunities for tokenizing anything
and
establishing ownership by just giving
the wallet address and not revealing who
owns the toilet address
so that that's a that's an interesting
proposition
and then from that point on like the
whole ecosystem
exploded um there have been a lot of
layer one
layer zero there are two protocols that
have helped try to um scale the
solutions out uh i think this this slide
is probably outdated and this new
information out available there but one
of the limiting factors is how many
transactions can you process per second
because if you want if you want to do
something at a web scale uh you would be
probably processing trillions and
trillions of transactions per second
and and this the the technology right
now is not mature to that level yet
and
some of the problems faced around around
the architecture of these blockchains is
is a scalability trilemma where you can
you can have one side of this triangle
so you can have something that is secure
and decentralized like bitcoin that
that's not scalable you can have
something that is scalable and secure
which is more centralized um
but
but not sufficiently decentralized and
the other side is possible as well
something scalable and decentralized but
not secure
um so
uh it's a it's a balancing act right now
and a lot of innovation is kind of in
this space um the protocol layer itself
is being defined
uh so that that's the backdrop and uh i
want to now tie in how data and ai plays
into this like data is termed as the new
oil uh and ai is basically decision
making at scale
and
if you talk about
on-ramp like which is
how do you bring data and ai to
blockchain
intrinsically they are like oil and
water they don't mix
data heavy and compute heavy operations
are not well suited for blockchain
the whole compute capacity is very very
small um and if you are let's say
training a neural network with
server and and data being into two
different places and you're having
transactions that going to and fro it's
just not going to be
very scalable
um so yeah i mean that kind of
introduces the need for hybrid
ecosystems
and um while we're designing these
hybrid ecosystems you have to then
do the exercise of mapping how value
flows between different uh agents of the
ecosystem and we need to like really
closely identify
who are the value creators in the system
and who are who are the value consumers
in the system
so like for example if you want to
understand the the actors involved in
the ai space there will be people who
would be doing data labeling there'll be
people could be loading the data maybe
prepping the data
uh there'll be people training models
there'll be people evaluating models
these are these can be
roles or people
or
basically individual wallets or even
smart contracts so the identity is
kind of analogous to
actor here and how these actors interact
basically
creates the transaction that for for
which blockchains are required
goes for for data flows like you can
have a data creator people who are
generating data let's say if you have on
a test line you're driving around you're
generating a ton of data you can then
become a data creator a data curator is
one who increases the value of data
consumer is the one who's benefiting
from this data and if if the value flow
between these these agents is clear uh
then you can start pricing it um and
then you can start deciding incentive
structures which does not need
necessarily bad behaviors they could
they can get direct transaction with no
third party involved
okay so talking about like hybrid
ecosystems and how these
two things are very different
uh where ai is probabilistic uh it is
ever-changing um you have algorithms
let me uh to to guess at reality uh
blockchains are more deterministic the
state is kind of shared across the whole
network and they're permanent you can't
really all these smart contracts that we
create are immutable bits of bits of
knowledge if you change the smart
contract uh basically it invalidates the
whole proposition of having a blockchain
so they have to be permanent and
it's it's a system of recording facts
and reality it's not really designed for
stochastic calculations
so
how do we solve for this um
so that kind of creates uh
there there is something called a smart
hybrid contract a hybrid smart contract
and um i i can go deeper here but one of
the questions i have is like
in a in a deterministic system can you
use a deterministic system to create a
random number and i think this kind of
explains the whole
need for hybrid smart contracts
um
what do you think um is it possible to
create random numbers true random
numbers which are unpredictable
in a deterministic system
i hope i did not put everybody to sleep
i guess no
true uh because
uh
the hybrid uh smart contract is
different than the smart contract
um
but but how exactly different i mean
that's from my
intuition right yeah so the the way you
would probably create um a random number
is maybe look at the block hash and try
to use it as a seed
but
if somebody the miners are actually
calculating these block
blocks and they they are the ones
publishing the block so they have
knowledge of the block hash and they can
choose not to publish certain block
block hashes take a penalty and wait for
the random number
being generated to their liking which is
it creates a lot of problems uh in the
blockchain world that's where like
hybrid smart contracts are required
because
uh you need an oracle to provide you
that data
uh one of the examples like just to um
like highlight this uh let's say you
want to like give out an ice cream to
everybody if the local temperature
passes 80 fahrenheit the blockchain
itself has no notion of temperature
it's an external state and you can
infuse that data into into a smart
contract and then that the smart
contract would become a hybrid contract
the gotcha here is this this whole
proposition and and just not having the
capabilities to do random number
generation has
and some other other things have
made it pretty easy to hack smart
contracts and a lot of money has been um
lost and
burned just because of this
um so
the
one piece of question is writing smart
contracts is very different from writing
code in the traditional world
where you have the opportunity to fix
bugs where you have the opportunity to
you know
make frequent changes and updates and
releases in the blockchain world you
should be extremely extremely cautious
and sure before you publish a smart
contract because once it is on the
blockchain there is no way to delete it
um
so there is no undo button here and and
that means you have to audit the code
multiple times uh yeah and that's where
like it
a lot of like if you were just creating
applications it would be pretty easy and
fast to create applications but just
because you have to be super super super
super careful uh it takes time to
to create propositions from a blockchain
company
dhruv
um when you talk about generating a
random number you're talking about a
truly random number or pseudorandom
number
uh what i post what i posted in the
comments block was that
uh the
australian national university
has uh has a lab and they've hooked up a
quantum vacuum detector
and they will spit out random data based
upon the quantum data and that is
you know the quantum quantum vacuum data
uh is random data
yeah so so that would be a great uh
system which is not on blockchain though
like that's
that's an off-chain system that's a
traditional world system that we all
live in and understand so and and i'm
i'm still talking about pseudo-random
numbers not really it doesn't have to be
pseudo-random or true random but
unpredictable is the key here because
something is deterministic it's no
longer unpredictable you can you can
arrive at the same
um same number through understand all of
this code is public all of the
blockchain is has visibility into the
block hashes you are trying to
use as seeds and all those kind of
things so if you if you know the initial
state you can then derive the rest of
the uh ecosystem from it
um so yeah and that's that's what i
meant
so that that uh that basically uh
dovetails into the whole problem uh
whole proposition of an oracle uh oracle
actually is a way of combining
blockchain with something that is
impossible to do on blockchain so
integrating external data let's say
weather data or maybe a random number uh
if you want to push that
that random number onto the blockchain
and make it available for all the smart
contracts that's where you would
probably use an oracle uh there are many
of them available one of the projects
that i really like is chain link um
full disclosure i own some of this so uh
but this is not the only project out
there there are plenty of good ones
um this the diagram here actually
makes it pretty obvious what we're
trying to do is take any input any kind
of an api any kind of data source and
make it available on blockchain also it
can do the reverse where you can take
any kind of data from the blockchain and
make it available as an api in in the
traditional world and i think this is a
phenomenal piece that is required
um
one of the examples i think this little
this example will make this pretty clear
so chain link provides a decentralized
tamper resistant
source of external data to trigger this
settlement of a prediction market and
payment to the winners this is one of
the use cases
where uh i think 2020 like presidential
election
results were used to um
to drive this on-chain prediction market
for for a yield wars kind of a betting
app
and what is happening here is that uh
you have the the source of data
interface with a chain link node
if you have a single source of data it's
easy to corrupt that
if there is like smart contracts that
define logic based on
on this data one can easily choose to
fudge this data to gain an advantage and
there's probably incentive in there to
to be a bad actor in the system but what
chaining does is it it creates this
incentive structure of running a node
and the node you can have multiple nodes
and when when you're getting data into
the blockchain there is a consensus
algorithm among those nodes so if
multiple nodes agree
that's where you can define truth as
agreement between nodes
and then they get payment as a reward
for supplying high quality data
to the blockchain
now they can
in theory uh
decide to not provide good quality data
and benefit from the fraud and that
creates like this whole
system where uh you're trying to always
make it more profitable for the for the
nodes to do the right thing and it's an
interesting design exercises by itself
and
this this project itself is pretty
interesting just to read the
whole negotiation amongst uh value
propositions
uh but the most important one use case
that i really loved um and this is what
this came up in a hackathon we were
trying to do at work um is let's say if
you're a data provider or you basically
monetize data through apis
you don't have to do much right you just
you have two options you can either find
a person running a node and sell your
data to that node runner who can then
make it available in the smart contract
world
or you can then decide decide to like
run a node yourself and self sign your
data as an authority
um there is advantages to advantages and
disadvantages in both these approaches
but uh this is one of the best on-ramps
i have seen uh for taking a traditional
world of option analytics project and
making it available for distributed apps
um
also many people are getting into the
game aws now has like a 10 minute quick
start i'm not sure if you can read this
but aws already has like a 10 minute
quick start for running a chain link
node um and that kind of allows you to
do any kind of analytics integration
with uh blockchain and the good thing
about chain link is it doesn't it's
agnostic to what kind of protocol is
being used underneath you can tie it
with bitcoin and tie it with ethereum
solana whatever you you want to have you
can you can have the blockchain so
i think this is a very interesting
project uh
in general some of the other use cases
i'll just quickly go through them uh one
of them is
social media identity and domain names
so here
this twitter user is trying to associate
the twitter account to um a wallet
address which is basically an
unstoppable domain almost
analogous to a dot com domain but but in
the change but in the blockchain world
so
these kind of use cases are enabled then
you have
hybrid applications hybrid cloud and
blockchain applications here there's a
google weather service using chain link
node uh running a chain link contract
and then supplying that information to a
third party app which is not a
decentralized app so the end user is not
a blockchain user but you can still use
blockchain to
have proper auditing
this one is pretty interesting though
so this is a privacy preserving data
query and it kind of dovetails into zero
knowledge proofs
but if you remember the purpose of a
data database design from mit csi csil
what they were trying to do
is already being achieved by by this
kind of infrastructure where
this person has certain um
bank deposit
a certain amount in the bank
and the smart contract uh requires the
the
the amount to be greater than let's say
5000. but if we do a query and we
publish this information to the
blockchain then it becomes
uh apparent to everybody how much money
this person has and we can't do that so
that's where like chain link nodes kind
of offer create an obfuscation layer and
they can decide logic
um is the amount greater than 5000 if
yes
you know that that signal is sent and
that kind of
provides the mechanism for having
purpose aware um queries
and and that's pretty exciting and it's
already solving real problems that that
are there in in web 2.
so um that's just one project right like
in this this ecosystem
oh
am i going back yes
sorry messed up the flow
here so there are other uh other
blockchain projects that are that are
coming up
and this space is exploding it's it's
hard to mention each one of them i'll
give you one example which i really
liked and it kind of
aligns the incentive mechanisms
better between the between the players
so you can already see like there are
applications of blockchain for ai and
finance medicine supply chains
um there's
academic research that is actively
happening in this area
and this this awesome blockchain ai
projects repo is it probably does a
great job explaining all other possible
projects and use cases out there
so this this is ocean protocol and this
is
another
um
another blockchain ai project which is
centered around data and data economy
what they want to do is create a
marketplace where people who can own
their own data they can submit the data
to the ocean protocol
and what that would result is is a is an
nfd associated with their data
um
there could be people who can submit
compute and algorithms to the blockchain
and then basically get uh
get an nft or a or a unique token for
the compute algorithm that they have
submitted
and then um they would be like consumers
of the analytics that is kind of created
as a result of uh you know data
interacting with compute
and the the people who are consuming the
analytics can then buy the analytics and
pay it back into the network so there's
like value creators here and then
they're like value consumers here and uh
this project kind of strives to create a
digital marketplace for exchange of
value where you're getting directly
monetized you can you're monetizing your
own data
uh also people who are like yeah
enthusiasts or creators are
basically monetizing their compute which
is pretty exciting um i mean
this is still pretty nascent i haven't
seen
huge projects out there using this
protocol but um i'm i'm closely watching
this space and i'll leave it at that
so
just a tip of the iceberg this this
space is
very
like
booming with with kind new projects and
technologies thrown out to us
now there are call outs uh this is not
without risk uh for the first callout is
there's no undo buttons so if you mess
up you mess up really big especially
there's money at stake so
um
there are test nets to do your
development and there are ways to um
like have audits and
um proper uh
kind of safeguards around your smart
contracts but sometimes there might be a
bug which nobody knows that is
discovered and it kind of leads to bad
results on unexpected outcomes but that
happens with any kind of a new new age
technology i think even with computers
we can still get hacked this is not um
not new
and um there are problems and then
people come up with solutions for it so
but it's good to be aware that
whatever you do is a solid rock rock
solid you can't change it
uh the other thing is uh like there is a
possibility like if smart contracts
start having uh
mathematical abilities than humans it is
possible let's say um a bot doing
trading becomes better than everybody
else and then starts accumulating wealth
um and basically sucks up the whole
wealth of the whole ecosystem so there
is a possibility for that and that you
can't take it down because it's on the
blockchains you just have to shut down
the whole blockchain which is this is
like shutting down the whole internet
which is really it destroys the whole
ecosystem that happens so there is
potential for that and again that you
have to be very very cognizant and
responsible for developing these smart
contracts so again like it does kind of
put your responsibility on you to not do
things like this
um and you don't need
blockchain i think this is one of the
questions you have to
ask yourself before even stepping into
this world is do you really need the
blockchain for for doing things like if
you really want to be careful about
trust and privacy you can use federated
learning for example you don't
necessarily have to go to blockchain for
the solution
but it does give you some additional
uh capabilities for aligning incentive
structures so
that
so that completes
what and why
when would this be mature enough
there's a lot of unknowns especially
regulation um
if you're running a node you become
um
you become
an agent in the network where you have
there's an additional requirement of
doing kyc on you and all those kind of
things that are already there and build
back writer plan and
this is also an evolving area
everybody's trying to understand how do
we regulate this because this kind of
deals with finances and and property and
value
so
it's not going to be straightforward and
policy makers don't have an incentive to
adopt something really new because the
downside might actually offset the
upside for for them personally so this
it's going to be interesting to see how
this expands
um also
we if we want this to to happen like we
have to really prove out real world use
cases where blockchains kind of improve
the system or situation or the whole
ecosystem
and there aren't much there like right
now we have games nfts maybe d5
trying to play around with with these
use cases but they're still
pretty far away from a normal person
and
unless a normal person starts seeing
value it's going to be very hard to
prove prove otherwise
also developer adoption this is
something that is in our control we can
choose to learn these technologies and
adopt them faster and that kind of
improves the
option rates but it's it's only if if
you are interested in that area so
that kind of drives when this will
happen if you are interested in going
about this there are
some good resources uh the ones that i
really liked uh this is a platform
called build space they are
free open to use they do small
week weekend projects you can sign up if
you complete the project they will give
you an nfd for that as well um
it's not worth anything but it gives you
a sense of recognition
also they they were the fastest on-ramps
for like solidity and rust for me uh
which are the two main languages that
are used for uh writing smart contracts
so
um
uh it was a pretty
pretty interesting experience but yes
like you would definitely need uh
familiarity with these uh languages rust
is not that commonly used so it's it's a
little hard and the learning curve is
steep uh solidity is kind of like
javascript so it's easy to understand
but again the whole concepts of like
immutability and
how do you write algorithms that are
extremely well tested and
you're sure of the ordering and
sequencing of things um fall in line
with how the miners kind of evaluate or
compile your code so it does involve a
deep
initial study but once you are there it
starts becoming obvious from from that
point on
um so just to conclude again i'll
reiterate like these are exciting times
uh there's intersection of two different
uh growing ecosystems and whenever there
is something like this there's
there's a lot of new uh
new in size new opportunities for
everybody involved in ecosystem also we
have an opportunity to design uh things
better and align incentive structures so
that we can have a better
experience for everybody in generations
to come maybe downstream so i'm i'm i'm
excited about kind of like contributing
to this space
anyways uh that's that's it um i would
love to hear any questions or
let's see like how the sentiment is now
like did i make a difference uh
like did i convert any threes and fours
into twos or once i don't know
i would love to know um and any
questions
hey two um i see mark still stick with
three now
um
if that was that was a four that was a
four okay what's up you've gone up
number four
two or three
okay let's say and then uh great
improvement
um okay so so um juve if you don't mind
i have a question um
when you were
uh throwing the question you know
the reward or choice do people really
have choice when they are facing the
rewards uh nowadays you know the the
banks are offering or the credit card
companies are offering right
so so what what's what's your um
insights on that i'm curious
so uh and i think the the way i have
written their rewards is not like just a
one-time reward it's
it was more in context with
reinforcement learning so if you if you
do certain actions and you get rewarded
for it the actions start having value
and if you have a choice between two or
three actions and certain actions have
more value for you you your behavior
automatically shifts towards
um
like up taking actions that that that
maximize value for you so it there is a
notion of choice but over time um you
can condition behaviors like you can
condition condition rats to
uh push a little button and and then you
can starve them the whole day and give
them little
piece of bread at the end of the button
push which which basically they learn
this on a stimulus queue let's say if
you have a chime or something whenever
there is a chime and i push a button i
get a reward um so if you can condition
any kind of an intelligent agent with
reward
uh it's very very difficult to separate
out choice
after some time
and like the whole idea of free will um
especially in a in a democracy
um it is important and you have all
these agents right where you're being
rewarded with dopamine centers being
activated uh pleasure centers being
activated through likes or the amount of
information pushed to you
people are able to condition the rewards
for you right now and if they can
condition the rewards they can condition
your choice which is kind of scary
but
that's where it was coming
from right
thank you thank you that's um yeah we
should definitely do better jobs um
how to design
you know quote unquote good rewards
uh depending on you know the good
behaviors right right so for example
right now the only incentive for a
platform like facebook for generating
money is if they increase the engagement
of the user with the platform
um because if they increase the
engagement they can push more ads which
kind of helps them so this is the
incentive structure that we have created
it's very hard for facebook to walk away
from that uh it's very hard for for a
platform to do good uh to grow greater
good and take a hit themselves so it's
it's just unintuitive the way things
have been designed
um
the whole business model and if this
exchange was was direct you did not need
a third party maybe the market supply
and demand kind of figured out the
pricing and everybody
who whoever was like creating value in
the system was rewarded for accordingly
um so
that that kind of creates the
opportunities
hopefully that is clear
yes definitely um i see uh julio uh pop
up the question in the chat
um
so does that mean
that there is no free will since all our
actions are meant to seek pleasure
and avoid pain etc
um
okay
there is free will you can still choose
to be sick
many people do choose to be sick
but the cost is pretty high
and i'm not sure how many people are
willing to pay that cost so if it
definitely acts as a dead parent um
over time and that that's my take
um but people there are people who are
just you know they like to do things
um in a
defined manner and they go against the
system choose to get get themselves
punished but yet do take different
actions and maybe they become pioneers
in the system
so i don't know like we do have uh free
will but it is possible to condition
that free will and that's my point
all right um
any other questions um
you're free to amuse yourself
if you have any question
drew but i have a i guess a question
slash comment i came to start i didn't
really know much
and i can i can understand a lot of the
motivations you're talking about but i
haven't really gotten to where it's
what this is doing is changing something
in the world like
how this adoption is going to make
something better for me
but i am aware of this is coming at a
huge cost and compute and energy
consumption to do the computations
and i'm just wondering how a system like
this is going to find a foothold and
then
you know take over enough to do
something and is that
energy and computation like i can't buy
a a
graphics card now because of all this
stuff is this is this gonna be worth it
yeah so it's a pretty valid question and
i think there's a lot of
land narratives going around in the
media it's like especially uh around
energy and compute
um
there are like the proof of work systems
do have do have the problem of being
energy and efficient but the proof of
stake systems are not um so it's
possible to
become a validator or a miner with much
lesser hardware requirements if many
systems choose to move to proof of stake
and that's where i think ethereum is
starting to move towards
um
but yes like for sure like we haven't
really seen this uh
change people's lives so far
um a couple of examples that i've seen
like maybe el salvador uh kind of
adopting bitcoin as a payment mechanism
it's still the way that the change is
coming about is to go against
traditional systems where
uh they had to pay like a huge
percentage of uh
the currency exchange fees as a forex
fees and that's kind of taken away
because now bitcoin is one of the ways
of change exchanging value uh that's
where i i see like uh things becoming
more efficient i would say rather than
the the inefficient systems where there
was always a regulator in between or a
middleman in between trying to control
the system and then that middleman that
basically gets too much power and gets
corrupted and then the whole system kind
of slows down to a halt
so
the idea of having conditional smart
contracts replacing this middleman
has potential for everybody
and it again like if there is real
advantage of building system only then
it will survive otherwise it will just
die down over time so
that that's one of the key design uh
questions that i think is unanswered in
my mind um
but hopefully we'll we'll see some of
these use cases emerge
um
some things are really important like so
one of another actually another thing
that comes to my mind is uh there's a
blockchain called trial it's a token on
ethereum blockchain
and they're trying to put all of the
clinical trial data on onto the
blockchain so it's like visible to
everybody and verifiable
if things like that come about
maybe that changes the perception around
okay
the vaccine was made with the right
ingredients or the the work that was
done or the experimental
data that was uh submitted is all there
and verifiable so the the cost to verify
goes down over time
uh and that's the biggest advantage i
see from this from this whole ecosystem
all right um
thank you to um so i see another
question from dylan uh i'm not a member
of any other any taos at this point
um yeah being on an h-1b visa i'm kind
of scared uh with the regulatory
implications of uh
of participating in this ecosystem
uh
it's
it's pretty easy to be
conceived as
external work and i'm only allowed to
work for my employer and on an h1b visa
so doing anything external to it and
that's just my own personal problem not
everybody else's but yeah there's a lot
of dows um coming in and the whole idea
for dao is a decentralized autonomous
organization
where the community kind of votes on
propositions and decides the the rules
of what the organization will behave
like
um
and it's pretty exciting like that's
that's one way of doing governance
and governance is hard
that's that's all i'll say
uh one of the things that uh i had a
similar discussion in a blockchain
meetup group
um
that
we're talking about web web 3 or the web
as a communications
backbone or platform etc
but uh
businesses can create
their own
consortia
name whatever kind of whatever kind of
uh organization
a multi-corporation organization for
uh doing trade or or doing manufacturing
or or the like the supply chain in and
of itself
yeah so this doesn't have to be
something that is open to everybody and
i think that's that that is left out of
a lot of introductions
that
just because we're we're talking about
the web doesn't mean that anybody
can get to can get into this
and
participate in it this this is something
that may be set up for
a group of corporations that participate
in a manufacturing
process so you've got
parts suppliers and then assemblers and
then final assemblers and and
distributor distribution networks
transportation etc
exactly
and and uh
in in under
and understanding this that that's
probably important
uh to bring out
yes i think the the whole idea of making
these
like tradable on exchanges and putting
monetary value on the tokens kind of
kind of forces the notion of that this
is for everyone it doesn't have to be
like it could be for a restricted
ecosystem um and
it could be like a barter system amongst
that ecosystem right like and they can
decide with with a token that they get
passed on so they they create their own
system of exchange of value and and
that's that's perfectly okay and they
have traceability and accountability in
the whole
system i agree
well
i would like to thank you everybody for
giving me the time to to talk to you i
know zoom fatigue is real and like
another meeting so late in the day is
pretty pretty bad tiring so it's it's
nice to still interface with the
community
thank you for the attention
thank you drew a really impressive
presentation format uh because this is
my first time seeing
this kind of format of presentation uh
very fancy
thank you
um
we still have some time
for lightning talks
i'm not quite sure
if anybody can
share what you've been doing recently
any
new ideas we want to share with
everybody
during lightning talks
uh feel free to jump in
i i've got a lightning talk if um
if you'd like
yeah yeah why not please mark
okay let me share
my screen
so can you see my notebook
yes i can
okay
so the last lightning talk i gave this
is this is kind of a theme that i've got
going on in my head which is
um
looking at at your python code uh where
you might be doing a lot of iteration
and looking for looking for ways to
think
of the data in sets
uh rather rather than
uh something that you iterate through
um
and sergio um his presentation he showed
sql and sql is a fine example of looking
at your data and operating on your data
in sets
so
uh somebody posted a
a
a prob pro posted a problem and wanted
to wanted it to say
well if you were given a given a string
uh such such as
a a b b b
whatever
um what was the uh the letter
that that had the longest sequence and
be able to put out
some sort of sent representative
analysis sentence uh programmatically
the longest sequence is b
and b occurred
five times
and they posted the code that their code
python code
and
here they're walking through the code
looking for adjacent letters to see
whether they're the same letter or
they're a different letter and this
really wasn't working for them and i i
just
kind of
went oh oh my gosh please let's let's
not do let's not do so much iteration
because
of course if you know me we have regex
regular expressions are a real powerful
way of processing strings
in the
re
um
re library in python you have two
methods
find all and find enter and find all
gives you all of the matches the catch
is that if you're using capture groups
this changes the behavior changes the
output so
for instance
if my regular expression
is to look for any letter
that is
repeated
one or more times
it's not going to quite give me the the
what i expected because it's only going
to give me
um
that first
that first group so i have to change the
the the regular expression pattern so
that i have two capture groups
and what was
slash backslash one
referencing that that uh
letter
now has to go to backslash two and find
all gives me both
the
grouped match
and that first le and that first letter
so that i i need to be able to calculate
the length
of that sequence to be able to determine
the longest one
on the other hand find enter gives you
two gives you two
outputs the group output and the span
output
and
um
so
the group output
uh can just be group
with uh nothing in the parentheses zero
in the parentheses or one in the
parentheses
and that
will determine
what you um
what you are actually capturing it's a
reference to the entire match or to the
the particular capture
um
so
a group
with no no parameter is the same as
group zero
and then
in our particular case
group one is
this capture
um
this capture that we're using to
to do a back reference to
um
and then the spans are the actual
positions uh if you're familiar with
python this would be equivalent to a
slice with the first two parameters
a slice
function
so
once a once i've got
find enter in this particular case i can
i can subtract
the uh the two parts of the span
to give me
uh
some number that i could calculate a max
and then
based upon that i can actually i can
actually say
well
the longest sequence is
and make a reference and this is a
formatted string so let me
not confuse people it's a
is mx mx1 1
and mx0
so please enter a string and in this
particular case uh it was
using the input function and i just
typed aabb
and it came comes back and says the
longest sequence is b repeated three
times
as with most most things uh everything
comes down to packaging so i need to
take that code and put it into a
function
and
here's here's
all of it all of the statements
but i i make
instead of mx
make the the variable
max group length
and
so in
using the
calculation of
the group length i can also
use group zero and apply the length to
that so i can act
so i can do
this uh group length two different ways
using the length function or using the
span using that span function that i
showed earlier
and then returning the group the max
group length and the longest group keys
um
testing it with i started to think a
little bit outside the box what if i've
got two longest
so i've got the bbb and the ooo
and now i've got
the results are
5 for the length and b and o
for
the actual keys themselves
um
how am i set on time
hello we still have like uh 15 minutes
mark
oh
yeah but this is a lot this i don't want
to take that long for
for a lightning talk uh
i'll i'll quickly go through this uh
james james wisnet uh over in the python
group uh told me that there's probably a
lot a library written to do whatever you
want to do in python
and
when i when i looked at well how would i
do it not using regular expressions the
the thing that came up was group the
group by function or method within the
intertools library
and this is the this
particular problem was the problem used
in the documentation
to describe what a group by can do
and
it will give you it will give you for
each group
the key
and then it will it would give you like
the items in the key a a and a
i don't really need the items but i do
need the count of those items and here's
a little trick
if you just need the count of something
you can use the sum function
and just someone for
however many items there are in the
group so it kind of was a way of uh
iterate of
going through that iterator generator
with with
a few a very few number of steps
um also
since i'm only interested in
sequences where we've got um ascii
characters or the ascii letters a
through z
i have to limit
the the group keys that i capture to
those that are in the ascii letters
once again apply a max
and i can
with max spec specify
uh what is used for the for the key for
the calculation
and
i don't need the whole group i just need
the count
and then i use that count later
as i go as i go through and say
everything that's a group key
uh that the the group count is equal to
that max
it's good to go so
there's just testing the concept
packaging packaging everything up
and wrote my own brake detection which
is just
hey
is
are two consecutive characters not like
the same or not the same
and
packaging that up
throwing a lot of different um
uh
a lot of different conditions to this
just what the original string the some
non-character non-letter character is
the longest so i certainly don't want to
pick it
i've got multiple long sequences the
first
the first sequence the is the the
longest the last sequence is the longest
um and maybe i've got the
duplicate characters so i've got
five b's
five o's and another five b's
and here's a trick when doing when doing
your
when doing your testing if you have
multiple
uh functions that do the same thing you
can create a a
list of functions
and then pass that function into into
your test
so that your test
will then
use that particular function
on that run
and
that was the
that was the uh
um
that was the lightning talk
any questions
before i stop sharing
crickets
okay
thank you mark
um
anyone else i mean uh if you do have a
question uh feel free to unmute yourself
otherwise
you'll want mark
i just made a comment like crickets are
just silent agreement that's what i've
understood
in zoom calls
well in in the comedy world crickets are
not a good thing
any other comments on cricket
reply
i appreciate it that was a good
presentation especially about the druid
and the cryptocurrency i don't really
understand that well but
it's cool
thank you aaron
thank you all right uh if uh nobody have
has any other
lighting talks uh i guess that concludes
our
event today
and i would like to
thank you all for coming and
happy
wish you all happy
new year and happy 2022
and i
i hope i uh we can
see you again um in march
um
and um we have
a
new announcement coming from our
um
meetup uh app or any registration app
you are on right now
uh
more to come okay and um
i'll see you in march
uh is that march
right mark is that march or february
and march okay good
first wednesday of the odd months
yep
yep that's correct
all right happy new year everybody and
um have a nice night thank you
bye